freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
die heutige folge ich weiß ich sag das
oft ist wirklich besonders denn ich
koche für kevin kevin rom ist und er ist
ein professioneller koch
stellvertretender küchenchef in schloss
elmau wie klingt das bitte der typ weiß
auf jeden fall komplett wie man kocht
und ich musste heute von meinen
kochkünsten überzeugen
jetzt glaub ich würde sagen kennen kann
aber wahrscheinlich eher so ein bisschen
der feinen küche zu ordnen aber
nichtsdestotrotz darf mir geht mir so
ein bisschen was von mir wird zum
frühstück die machen breakfast burger
wir fangen an dem wir uns zwei gemüse
zwiebeln schneiden bei den spielen wir
um unten ab die zwiebel halbieren wird
und jetzt schneiden wir sie der länge
nach entscheiden so leer wie genauso
zwiebeln sehen uns hier so ein top 14
auf und schmecken dass geburten coole
leute kevin ist jetzt auch alle kommen
kommen wir einmal ins bild sein
servus kay wird übrig sollte auch für
mich kochen und es gibt was ganz kleinen
ist nämlich risotto das kommt noch ein
genie zeitgleich online natürlich könnte
gerne wenn ihr fertig seid ihr recht zu
calvin drüber und euch das mal anschauen
sie mal lieber kann sich jetzt ganz
entspannt zurück lebens beschäftigt
streitig machen stellt fertig ich
genieße es halt war überhaupt während
eine schöne wir bereiten jetzt hier den
werken auf wacklig mit abend wohl ihr
aus und der backofen 2 grad an gemacht
ist aber nicht besonders vor geistlosen
gegeben jetzt einfach gemeinsam einen
des re trotzdem der schon christian
reform zirka 20 minuten jetzt sei es
zucker dazu acht eier sparen wir hier
ein
zudem geben wir zwei stiche mutter dann
zu hause hier sehen die zwiebel ankara
realisieren hier drüben ist das ei
weiter am stocken
[Musik]
wir machen jetzt die spicy mails mit
scharfem einlesen soße dazu also wie ein
juristischer soße wir haben mal wir
haben stadt und das bringt jetzt einfach
zu sagen er will eben mal ganz kurz weil
man muss die idee des trüben
da geben wir zu nachgeschmack erst mal
ein bisschen von den jeweiligen saucen
dazu war sehr dominant ist roger ist
sehr scharf rochester worcester
geschmacksintensiv deshalb vorsichtig
seit stockt langsam
wir nehmen ist jetzt auch direkt von der
hitze runter so ihr seht ist es leichter
im stock in irland sind und jetzt im
bilde
nochmals ein stich butter hinzu und wenn
die mutter eingerührt ist wenn jetzt
noch einen großzügigen esslöffel senf
dazu das macht das ganze sehr klinik die
rühren wir auch unter jetzt gehen ja
unseren schnittlauch dazu wir haben es
unter gerührt und jetzt geht es wieder
auch die jetzt der grill ist vorgeheizt
sagt euch leute burger brötchen merken
dass auf die auf dem grill angetastet
werden oder einer pfanne und sein
thorsten wir auch unsere bürger brötchen
daran schließt das also ein bisschen das
noch vom leben nichts drankommt
dann geben wir ein bisschen salz pfeffer
dazu wird auch zeit zum zusammenbauen
unsere runter seiten der bürger da
konnte guter klacks von der maria braun
sodann kommt dazu ein ordentlicher
klacks von unseren kanalisierten
zwiebeln die hätten wir noch ein
bisschen brauner werden lassen können
aber das ist super so dann nehmen uns
unsere division bürger viel aus noch ein
bisschen mehr kanalisierte zwiebeln bei
affen machen das hier abfahrt
die ausgerückten sodann geben jetzt
unsere käse drauf das ist schändlich
leute kann ich diese benutzen
damit schmilzt mir das ganze ein
bisschen an wirklich ich will sich schon
so lange benutzen gehen wir den welten
auf die oberseite und dann schließen wir
auch schon den bürgern
[Musik]
es ist soweit es hat ein bisschen länger
gedauert als gedacht aber das ergebnis
ist dafür umso hübscher das sieht aus
leute wirklich diese verschiedenen
schichten und sie wirklich so saftig aus
also ich bin sehr gespannt weil es
schaut ehrliche auswirken nach gaddafi
deswegen bin ich umso gespannter ja du
kennst das spiel den ersten bissen dann
ist man auf sich wirken geht die kamera
aus und der renault 16 bewertung
okay noch das ding verputzt ich bin hier
noch bei den vorlaufzeiten aber wirklich
man beißt im nachhinein und alles fällt
raus oder kannst ja gerne schon mal
deine gedanken dazu zu sagen also ich
war am anfang ein bisschen skeptisch als
sie gesagt dass wir machen leuten break
des bürgermeisters noch nie gehört lasse
mich aber natürlich immer gerne auf neue
sachen nein zum burger der bürger hat
das brötchen an und für sich mega soft
also wirklich schöne tostedt auf dem
grill draußen dass man schon mal super
fundament der becken mega knusprig das
aber total soft wirklich schon gewartet
bis gesehen habe ich so auch selten
gesehen ist das wirklich super gemacht
die mayo war lecker und die zwiebeln
bringen die schöne süße rein also ist
ein gedicht also dich ich habe noch nie
gesagt habe ich noch nie gegessen und
das hat meine erwartungen betroffen kv
seinem und zuhört als jemand der
wirklich ein erfahrenes professionell
zehn jahren 13 jahre professionell
küchen erfahren dass freue mich wirklich
sehr also ich kann aber auch zu der käse
netanya mega mega abgeliefert was heißt
das in der b note von 0 bis 10
ja also ich glaub da kann ich nicht
weniger minuten also wirklich wirklich
kraft ehrlich krass wie gesagt dass
brink hat mich total geflecht überrascht
und abgeholt kraft das freue mich
wirklich richtig geil dass ich dachte
heute purzelt hier mein kopf aber den
tag nicht vor rahmen zum mittagessen
abendessen stehen noch an
wir sehen uns zum mittagessen und wir
sind beim mittagessen angekommen hat ihr
seht es bereits ein neues baby ich habe
mir die im blick roddick bezogen und
dann werde ich jetzt tag machen findet
ihr kennt ja mein rezept also das rezept
100 vermählt bei 3 300 gramm drei eier
kleineberg muss dann habe ich hier drei
eier wieder so kommen sie auch noch
übrig die bis jetzt zum ersten mal
überhaupt benutzt dann mache ich wie
auch normale piste so eine coole party
fire rain so wir geben jetzt einen haken
bei und jetzt mache ich die maschine zum
ersten mal an so heute ein traum
ohne alles mit den händen verknetet zu
haben habe ich jetzt hier den teig durch
mal hier über knetet einmal ein bisschen
mit den händen zusammen mit der wirklich
glatt ist sondern denke ich jetzt kurz
eben frischhaltefolie wo sie erst jetzt
ein leichtes pesto ein frisches pesto da
fange ich an in dem ich hier 50 ps in
einer unbeschichteten fall einfach
anders und in der zwischenzeit muss man
natürlich bereiten wir aber schon mal
die anderen sachen von den videos mit
kevin geprägt haben ein neues wort
gelernt schloss sich nämlich schloss
sieges otto gemacht und das ist keine
fantasie worte und das ist echt ein
konsularischer begriff tatsächlich
schaffen es jetzt 2 knoblauchzehen hallo
was geht ab so was ich mache ich koche
dafür den spät verpflichtenden
küchenchef von schloss elmau
das geht bei dir aus der wäsche
nein ich hab zwei du kannst du gerne da
habe ich jetzt hier dreihundert
basilikum und die zog ich einfach hier
ab gibt die schon mal in unser glas
hinein wo ist denn gleich mixen werden
so hier ist unser basilikum dazu geben
jetzt einfach schon mal den knoblauch
pinienkerne online panel
dazu kommen jetzt 250 milliliter also
wirklich ne ganze menge
unsere pinienkerne sind jetzt auch schon
schön angelastet wir können jetzt auch
schon hinter zu geben
man kommt hierzu noch eine gute prise
meersalz
jetzt ist auch schon gern teilen für
unseren standmixer also dann läutet
jetzt so 50 gramm kann mir sagen so viel
ist das jetzt schicken wir unsere 50
gramm kam es da an einfach dazu und
heben das ganze vorsichtig runter bin
ich wirklich so dass mundl woche ist
schon fast am kopf das heißt es wird
jetzt höchste zeit dass wir das hier
meine linie maschine aufbauen
dann muss hier noch mal nicht mehr auf
die arbeitsfläche machen sondern ich
führe jetzt den tag mein mann kann nicht
das ganze jetzt hier zu einem vorwahl
form und dann gehe ich jetzt hier die
verschiedenen stufen von der
nudelmaschine einmal durch zwischendurch
kann man immer so ein bisschen mehl
dazugeben habe mithin diesen lauten teil
teller auf sollst du die paste annehmen
kannst mehr als du brauchst ist der arme
kerl hier mit anpacken
die passt haben nehmen wir auch kommen
bin sehr zufrieden
tatsächlich beträgt nicht verarbeiten
bekommen weiß was im rhein direkt geben
kommen mir jetzt ich mache in der
zwischenzeit ein bisschen klatsch shift
oder für die extra mile gewiss ja mach
ich jetzt noch mal eine neue packung
pinienkerne auflöste die noch mal frisch
an und schnell fornika cherrytomaten
[Musik]
ok wenn der film mittagessen hoffe du
bist schon wieder hungrig ja auf jeden
fall
ich bin sehr gespannt oder verliere die
ganzen geschicke im hintergrund ein
bisschen beobachtet hoffe du hast nicht
die ganze zeit gedacht und wenn wir wer
was macht er da ich habe mir den ein-
oder landete patrick buck neben den
tieren sehr professionell gemacht
doch echt schön lang super hat nichts
schlimmeres wieso findet okay wir sagen
nicht mehr das schon ganz okay zu sein
wir sehen uns gleich wieder wenn auch
gegessen ist jetzt interessiert mich
natürlich einmal mehr seinen urteilen
dann gewährt also erst mal vorab muss
man ja auf jeden fall mal klar stellen
weil es wahrscheinlich einige erwarten
ebenso teil der so locker oder warum hat
er da so keine ahnung wie zum frühstück
zum beispiel zehn punkte aus ich bin ja
nicht hier hin gekommen um erzählungen
wie den richter zu spielen sondern um
mir einfach fair zu werden dann hat man
eigentlich vergessen du auf jeden fall
mit sehr viel engagement und
enthusiasmus kost ihr zuhause der
privaten küche das ist ja auch komplett
andere umstände die ich das irgendwie
gewohnt bin ja echt toll job jetzt
dagegen einfach vorab sagen nein
verpasster sage ich auch ganz ehrlich
gibt es nicht viel auszusetzen
die nudeln war super die nudeln al dente
das ganz wichtig ich schon das pesto
waage ja mit der topnote super die
richtung marten ich dachte ganz ehrlich
was also wirklich ich kann nicht mehr
dazu sagen das ist kein ort kennen die
leute dich googeln und sich ok deloitte
google ihnen das ist erst wirklich
stellvertreten hat mich schnell erkennt
auch kein geld dafür dass er das sagt er
ich bin wirklich sehr glücklich ich
hoffe ich kann es irgendwie fortzusetzen
und aufrecht halten des abendessens
müssen das einfach dort zu machen dass
wir mal ein tränchen zeitung
hat zusammen mit smashed potatoes mit
rosmarin thymian knoblauch wird also
sehr schön sondern sehr schönes essen
und für sollen wir fangen an indem wir
die feine speisekartoffel nicht noch
drillinge weißen die auf oder dafür
nehme ich jetzt einfach mal die hälfte
der packung und hip hop und kochen sie
mit dem wasser aus und die zuerst
menschen die dann nicht so richtig schön
mit meiner smash burger presse ich gebe
es immer das kind in form einer
ofenkartoffel mit backpulver das hilft
nämlich die stärker abzubauen was das
herz noch weicher hat im endeffekt wenn
dies im backofen an den boliden will
schön durch rösten
wie kommen die kartoffel so 15 bis 20
minuten auf und wir können auch direkt
vor unserer zeit in boca vorbereiten
dafür nämlich eine hühnchenbrust wie
gesagt schneide ich einmal durch ich
habe das schon geschnitten wollte das
ganze platte jetzt probiere auch so eine
dicke von einem namen zentimeter zu
hören
okay ist heute in borken das kennt ihr
bestimmt vielleicht auch gar nicht ist
quasi eine sandwich aus schnitzel
ursprünglichkeit schnitzel und gefüllt
ist das mit salbei und parmaschinken der
sein reittier ist das leben wir hier so
rein wirken dass das ungefähr auf die
mädchen brust passt ich habe jetzt etwas
weiter nach oben draufgelegt und am ende
schwenken das ganze auch noch mal in
einer seiner mutter durch und was wir
jetzt machen wir die hälfte der
hähnchenbrust und legen sie oben auch
für sehr schön das ganze schließt ab und
damit das ganze gleich in der pfanne ab
zusammenhält müssen jetzt noch irgendwie
fixiert dafür nehmen wir also wir
stechen hier einmal durch hier kommen
wir wieder ich werde jetzt das halt die
blogger noch mit ein bisschen mehl
bestäuben ziehen das jetzt einfach
einmal rein warten noch eine sekunde
weil die kartoffel noch ein bisschen
länger brauchen
aber das ist ganz gut und es hat
wirklich super gut zusammen ich leide
jetzt ein bisschen knoblauch ist neben
hier noch ein zwei es in rosmarin und
wir bleiben schon fanden wir die
untersagt
für unseren verein will den gesamten
boden bedeckt ich jetzt einmal damit
jetzt lege ich einfach schon mal so
knoblauch würfelchen nach unten damit
die kartoffeln auch von beiden seiten
prämiert werden
bei den roten war ihm ein bisschen zu
den spielen wir auch ein bisschen rein
wir sind die guten und die gebe ich
jetzt einfach mal hier hinein nicht
wundern ist hier oben bisschen
angerostet es macht aber gar nicht weil
das ist neben kontakt mit lebensmitteln
wir bearbeiten das ganze nämlich jetzt
auch mit ein bisschen frank papier und
ober und ich drücke unter okay leute
okay das sieht auf jeden fall sehr schön
aus mehr olivenöl darüber wirklich meine
sportrechtliche knoblauch der restliche
rosmarin thymian ästchen jetzt kann das
ganze auch umgehend mit der offenheit
und keine ahnung wie lange aber auf
jeden fall so lange bis das knusprige
ich mache jetzt zu den kartoffeln eben
erst fertig werden meinte zum kleinen
kräuterquark beziehungsweise den flächen
schluck milch ein bisschen frischkäse
frische petersilie und spritzer
limettensaft ganz so wir gehen jetzt ein
bisschen öl hinein geht mir das heute
den bock auf die pfanne braten es auch
bei der anderen seite noch mal scharf an
und wenn das von beiden seiten
angebraten erst dann gehen wir wissen
runter plätze nehmen in die pfanne
zwischen der fsg teure sehr stimmen aus
leute dazu kommen jetzt unsere smashed
potatoes wenn tatsächlich ein bisschen
weich geblieben weil ich akzeptiere sie
wie sie sind gefroren habe mir noch ein
bisschen platz für unsere sour cream
[Musik]
das große finale am eresing bock vom
hähnchen gemeinsam mit smashed potatoes
und eine teetasse creme
ich bin sehr gespannt was du sagen
willst so oder so egal was du sagst ich
bin schon internet von dir will ich die
zwei top noten zu bekommen hat mich sehr
gefreut dass ich probier wie immer ein
wissens oder jacken oder okay okay leute
wir sehen uns zu bewerten so mein lieber
letzte mahlzeit des tages ist
aufgegessen deshalb unfertig spaß
gemacht also erstmal vielen dank dass du
zu gast war wirklich cool mit dir
vielleicht wieder einladend aus da komme
ich zur bewertung und ich bin sehr
gespannt was du zum abendessen sagt ein
bisschen geschmeckt hat ich bin großer
zeitdruck denn ich habe das bisher war
ihre klassischen mit country gästen die
mit hähnchen ja also unterscheidet sich
jetzt natürlich von mir vielleicht
münchen ist ein bisschen also die
üblichen kalt vom feld teil natürlich
nicht ich finde ich groß ist um den
heißen brei 18 8 von 10 8 von 10
wer nicht solide würde ich sagen dass
mir auch selbst gegeben ja und da mal
ehrlich ist also mit 28 von 30 punkten
von dir also von einem ausgewählten
profi koch der seit 13 jahren kocht und
den sternekoch könnte nicht glücklicher
sein jack unbedingt kevin haben ist
jetzt gerade auf seinem tal ab gehören
sagte das geht auch über 800 millionen
aufrufe will sie am nächsten sonntag um
14 uhr wieder macht holt bis dahin
tschüss hieß
[Musik]